autre action ce matin devant le
ministère de la santé à paris une
trentaine de militants d'attac et du
collectif intérieur gens sont remis le
prix du mépris au gouvernement suite aux
promesses des autorités sanitaires
ils ont aspergé la devanture du
ministère de la santé avec du faux sang
à les protestataires continuent de
demander de meilleures conditions pour
l'hôpital public écoutez ce action
c'était la remise d'une médaille pour le
ministère de la santé qui nous a promis
des médailles aussi et c'est le premier
prix du mépris parce que ça fait des
années qu'on énonce la situation à
l'hôpital public parce que les as des
années que cette situation que cette
situation est dénoncée ça fait quinze
mois avec le collectif intelligence que
les personnels des urgences se sont
agglomérés en disant c'est pas possible
c'est ici que cette situation on peut
pas on va pas de retour à la situation
initiale
nous on veut une amélioration de
l'hôpital public de la façon dont on
soigne et ça c'est quelque chose que
voilà on a été applaudi à 20 heures tous
les soirs hier je pense que les citoyens
en france se rendent compte du problème
et veulent un hôpital de bonne qualité
passé ainsi un système auquel on est
accroché en france cette action c'était
pour symboliser le fait que ce
gouvernement a des responsabilités
extrêmement importante à des milliers de
morts sur sur les bras a du sang sur les
mains puisque ça fait des années des
mois que les soignants nous alerte sur
le fait qu'il n'y a pas de moyens
suffisants pour nous soigner dignement
pas assez de moyens personnels passés en
lit